distinguido presidente distinguidos
jefes de esta de gobierno distinguido el
secretario general distinguidos
delegados en nombre propio y en el
nombre de mi país les saludo con todo
mis respetos Espero y
deseo que El sextogésimo séptimo
precesión estará la asamblea
generaciones unidas nos traiga los
mejores resultados para nuestro país y
para toda la raza humana también me
gustaría felicitar al Señor chapa
kuroshi por ocupar la presidencia de la
asamblea general el lema de la asamblea
general
nos parece que es el más adecuado para
nuestros tiempos
nos encontramos en un momento en el que
celebramos nuestra reunión Cuando
intentamos precisamente hacer frente a
distintos desafíos a escala mundial
una de las lecciones más importantes
aprendidas durante la pandemia me fue la
creación de la solidaridad internacional
para resolver amenazas globales durante
la pandemia sin discriminación no hemos
ofrecido ayuda humanitaria a más de 161
países y 12 organizaciones
internacionales
y también hemos ofrecido Turco back
es nuestra vacuna nacional y la hemos
ofrecido a servicios de toda la
humanidad el año pasado ratificamos en
la cuerda de París
para dar ejemplo de nuestra
determinación de luchar contra el cambio
climático en el
2053 nos queremos convertir en un país
de misiones cero
y
al celebrar la decimosexta reunión de la
conferencia de las partes de la comisión
sobre la biodiversidad queremos
demostrar que somos Pioneros en la lucha
contra el cambio climático por los
problemas causados en la cadena de
suministro
la economía global se ha visto muy
afectada y ahora vemos una nueva oleada
de choques por la guerra entre Rusia y
Ucrania los precios de los alimentos y
de las materias primas se incrementan la
inflación sube y esto puede tener
consecuencias graves para la economía
global y para el bienestar social
una vez más vemos lo importante que es
la garantía de la seguridad del
abastecimiento de energía en tanto que
Turquía desde el principio
nos hemos centrado en la energía no como
una cuestión de competencia sino un
ámbito de cooperación
aparte de las necesidades que teníamos
también hemos reavivado muchos proyectos
que apoyarían la seguridad energética no
solamente en nuestra región sino hasta
la global
y con lo que está aconteciendo en los
últimos tiempos hemos visto como esta
posición se ha visto confirmada también
Hablamos de la seguridad del
abastecimiento de alimentos nos
encontramos en El Siglo 21 y Hemos
llegado a el máximo de
oportunidades económicas y financieras
sin embargo todavía hay una quinta parte
del mundo que sufre del hambre de la
pobreza
el mundo estaba en camino para lograr la
pobreza acero y el hambre Cero en 2030
como parte de los ods pero parece que
nos estamos alejando de esta perspectiva
y de este objetivo
ahora tenemos que allanar el camino y
esto solamente podrá ser posible a
través de la solidaridad internacional y
necesitamos un enfoque justo
la vida cuenta de los desafíos
ante los que nos encontramos tenemos que
avanzar en tanto que Turquía queremos
demostrar esta voluntad tal y como hemos
hecho durante la pandemia también y
durante la crisis causada por el cambio
climático también
lo hemos demostrado al combatir la
crisis causado por el conflicto entre
Rusia Ucrania este conflicto ya lleva
más de siete meses y nos parece que la
guerra no tendrá vencedor
y necesitamos un proceso de paz justo es
importante hablar de la importancia de
la diplomacia para resolver conflictos a
través del diálogo por eso reunimos a
las partes en el foro diplomático de
antalya y también después en Estambul
para convertirnos en facilitadores del
proceso de reconciliación
como resultado de los grandes esfuerzos
desplegados junto con el secretario
general hemos logrado exportar
cereal ucraniano por el mar Negro y ha
llegado de esta manera a los mercados
globales la comisión de Estambul que ha
permitido esta exportación
sigue siendo capital y las exportaciones
están incrementándose a medida que
avanza el tiempo se trata de un acuerdo
muy importante
un acuerdo que se celebró también con la
colaboración de las Naciones Unidas y
uno de los logros más importantes de las
Naciones Unidas en las últimas décadas
me parece
que
la comunidad internacional recuperó la
confianza en las Naciones Unidas como
resultado de la convención de Estambul
porque demuestra que las negociaciones
pueden dar resultados sobre todo en
temas que resultan vitales para todas
las partes implicadas
él se sigue un enfoque parecido también
en nuestro caso en la cuestión de la
planta es la policía que amenaza la
seguridad de todo el planeta
el conflicto se recrudece y estamos
desplegando grandes esfuerzos para que
la guerra termine protegiendo la
integridad territorial y la soberanía de
Ucrania de una vez por todas y queremos
hacer un llamamiento a todas las
organizaciones internacionales y a todos
los países del mundo para que apoyen las
iniciativas
pacíficas de Turquía para resolver ese
conflicto necesitamos una salida digna
de esta crisis y esto solamente podrá
ser a través de una solución diplomática
que sea justa y que se puede aplicar por
otro lado todos estos desastres que
afectan a millones de personas
demuestran una vez más que las Naciones
Unidas tendrán que ser mucho más eficaz
tendrán que tener más influencia y las
Naciones Unidas tiene la responsabilidad
de desplegar más esfuerzos para resolver
los problemas es que la escala mundial
las Naciones Unidas tendrán que ser más
inclusivas y tendrán también que poder
generar soluciones para un mundo más
justo y las Naciones Unidas tendrán que
convertirse en una organización
internacional donde se pueda
plantear la voluntad de toda la
humanidad el Consejo de Seguridad tiene
que ser más eficaz tiene que ser más
democrático tiene que ser más
transparente tiene que rendir cuentas
tiene que ser más funcional y Esto será
En beneficio de toda la humanidad cuando
busque la paz la justicia y el bienestar
nos parece que será este un punto de
inflexión para todos nosotros y es
importante en que recordemos la
responsabilidad que tenemos entre todos
El mundo es mayor que unos cinco y
todavía es posible Tener un mundo más
justo Esto es lo que tenemos que seguir
repitiendo
cada oportunidad que tengamos estamos
comprometidos y desde luego que
Seguiremos luchando y Esperamos que todo
el mundo nos apoye Y esto es lo que les
quiero pedir a todos ustedes en el día
de hoy
distinguidas delegaciones nuestra visión
de la política exterior siempre es
orientado en La Paz Empezando por
nuestra región en todo el mundo hemos
trabajado para garantizar que la paz
siempre prevalezca en esta iniciativa
que defendemos que se titula mediación
por la paz y que hemos realizado bajo
los hospicios de las Naciones Unidas
hemos desplegado grandes esfuerzos para
resolver conflictos desde Europa a
América Latina desde África a distintas
partes geográficas intentamos
tener una posición de mediación y
también tenemos una posición de
facilitador para resolver controversias
una vez por todas estamos en el centro
de la región rodeado de conflictos pero
intentamos formar parte de la solución y
no tanto del problema y esto solamente
es posible con las iniciativas que
realizamos
en este marco
siempre subrayamos
que aquella era una solución permanente
a la crisis Siria
con arreglar la resolución 2254 del
Consejo de Seguridad
una solución permanente y viable
si se mantiene el conflicto de su
amenazará
la integridad territorial de Siria y la
seguridad y estabilidad de toda la
región
más de 4 millones de civiles de origen
sirio están en nuestro país
creo que el Consejo de Seguridad tendrá
que subir su la responsabilidades que
tiene para ampliar el mandato del
mecanismo humanitario establecido para
el noroeste de Siria
luchamos contra organizaciones
terroristas como el
y sus descendientes que cometen
atentados terroristas en nuestro país
y contra nuestras fuerzas de seguridad y
nuestros civiles
eso es una amenaza para la integridad
territorial de Siria
pedimos que se deje de utilizar estas
organizaciones como un arma nosotros
tenemos la capacidad de tomar medidas
contra el terrorismo entonces nunca
escaparemos de la lucha contra el
terrorismo y tomaremos las medidas que
sea necesario tomar
estamos tratando de hacer todo lo que
podemos para garantizar que nuestros
hermanos y hermanas sirios pueden volver
a su país en Una atmósfera de seguridad
y dignidad
estamos
tratando de mejorar
la situación para que los que escapan de
la guerra puedan volver a su Patria y
para que puedan tener una vida digna
estamos construyendo
100.000 hogares de ladrillo en varias
partes de Siria
para que ellos puedan alojarse allí la
mayor parte de estos
100.000 hogares ya han sido terminados y
han sido cedidos a sus propietarios y
hemos empezado preparativos para
construir otros 200.000
para que un millón de sirios puedan
volver a su país
se han creado zonas seguras en 13
centros y en las zonas Rurales
necesitamos la ayuda de la comunidad
internacional para que esto sea posible
queremos que todos muestren
solidaridad y compromiso
la migración irregular
y la crisis de los refugiados
no se puede resolver abandonando los a
su propia suerte
ni construyendo murallas en las
fronteras
dejándolos en campamentos de
concentración esta solución sólo se
puede alcanzar con esfuerzo que hagan
hincapié en el ser humano
podemos ver que los griegos
se han hecho mucho más crueles con
respecto a los migrantes del Mar Egeo y
del Mediterráneo Oriental nosotros no
queremos que
los cadáveres de niños como Island
termine de nuestras
playas pero Grecia está
empujando estos refugiados en forma
ilegal convirtiendo el Mar Egeo en un
cementerio para los refugiados la semana
pasada un niño de 9 meses de edad
llamado así y otro niño llamado abduck
de cuatro años de edad
murieron
porque los guardacostas
de Grecia hundieron sus botes
Creo que ya es
tiempo de que Europa y las Naciones
Unidas y otras organizaciones digan Ya
basta a estos crímenes que son crímenes
de esa humanidad
hay otro país vecino Irak donde estamos
haciendo esfuerzos para que se instaure
allí la paz y la estabilidad
queremos que haya Reconciliación
política y que se alcance una edad en el
marco de una identidad iraquí
para que la prosperidad sea sostenible
en Irak y para
impedir los atentados terroristas en ir
queremos que trabajar Unidos
nunca permitirá más las organizaciones
esta revistas en Irak y nunca dejaremos
de luchar contra
los atentados en Turquía cometidos por
las redes sociales provenientes de Irak
como he dicho muchas veces desde este
podio Vamos a luchar contra el
terrorismo
sin discriminación y vamos a poder
alcanzar el triunfo con una verdadera
solidaridad independientemente de cómo
se llame lucharemos contra el terrorismo
en todas sus manifestaciones y creemos
que nuestros amigos y aliados sean
solidarios y que asuman un compromiso
eso y es normal que nosotros esperemos
eso de ellos las organizaciones
terroristas
pero nosotros queremos colaborar con
ustedes para poder alcanzar la paz la
prosperidad de la estabilidad de nuestra
región y de todo el mundo
definidos delegados desde el punto de
vista de la seguridad del mundo
tenemos que
hacer hincapié
en el norte de África y Mediterráneo y
oriental
en este marco
es fundamental
establecer esta habilidad y bienestar en
Libia no es solo para el mundo sino para
la región
apoyamos los esfuerzos de las Naciones
Unidas en esta materia nosotros queremos
proteger
la soberanía del pueblo alivio así como
su unidad y su integridad
para que puedan alcanzar el nivel de
prosperidad que tanto desean
debe haber elecciones libres y justas en
Libia y se tiene que crear un gobierno
sólido por voluntad popular Esto es algo
a lo que todos tenemos que contribuir
para que se alcance la pase la
estabilidad en el medio oriente
necesitamos alcanzar una solución el
conflicto de Israel entre Israel y para
estirar una vez por todas a través de
una solución vía Estatal Esto es algo
que apoyamos firmemente estaremos que
mantener la identidad cultural e
histórica de Jerusalén y la santidad de
la mezquita de aljaram shariff y
detener los asentamientos ilícitos y los
territorios ocupados
y establecer seguridad para la vida y
las propiedades de los palestinos
necesitamos alcanzar una solución
permanente
a esta disputa
donde Jerusalén Oriental será una
capital y se establecerá un estado
palestino independiente y soberano no
hay otra alternativa
Esto es para los intereses de la región
para los intereses del pueblo palestino
del pueblo de israelí y de toda la
región y Seguiremos haciendo esfuerzos
para que esto sea posible
la comunidad internacional tiene la
responsabilidad de ayudar a los
refugiados
palestinos a través de logaritmo de
obras públicas y Socorro y darle mayores
recursos financieros
al mismo tiempo
nos preocupa
la situación en Irán
siempre hemos apoyado el plan conjunto
de acción
necesitamos diplomacia y diálogo para
resolver la disputa sobre el programa
nuclear de grande una vez por todas
Queremos crear una solución permanente
hacer
bella tiene que abandonar los
territorios ocupados
tenemos una oportunidad histórica para
alcanzar paz y estabilidad permanente en
el
cáucaso sur porque siempre ha apoyado
los esfuerzos entre azerbaiyán y Armenia
y queremos aprovechar al máximo esta
oportunidad
las escaramuzas en los últimos días se
arroja una sombra sobre este entorno
positivo pero seguimos pensando que se
puede alcanzar
una paz de carácter amplio entre estos
dos países siempre apoyaremos a nuestros
hermanos desde azerbaiyán para que
puedan construir Su futuro y sus hogares
de una forma justa
el las rutas de transporte de nuestra
región también son un motivo de
inquietud
si lográramos abrir esta rutas esto
contribuiría mucho al bienestar de toda
la región al mismo tiempo
Durante los últimos 50 años Afganistán
ha estado luchando contra el conflictos
terrorismo y pobreza
y ahora sigue pasando por una época muy
difícil
el gobierno interino debe tomar medidas
para garantizar los derechos humanos y
libertades fundamentales de la población
parece haber ciertos acontecimientos
prometedores y Seguiremos apoyando a
nuestros hermanos y hermanas afganos en
este proceso la India y Pakistán después
de haber establecido
su soberanía hace 75 años no han
alcanzado la paz y la solidaridad
entre entre ambos
esto es lamentable
Esperamos que se pueda alcanzar una paz
y tranquilidad y prosperidad permanente
en cachemira extendemos nuestra
condolencias al pueblo de Pakistán por
las horribles inundaciones que han
experimentado y después de estas
inundaciones hemos enviado ayuda
humanitaria y los seguimos enviando Qué
le vas a hacer un llamado a la comunidad
internacional para que ayuda al pueblo
de Pakistán durante
esta época tan desafortunada los
rojillas
deben poder volver a su país de una
forma voluntaria y digna y lo apoyamos
todo lo posible
somos sensibles
a la protección
de los derechos y libertades
fundamentales de los
musulmanes de Turquía de una forma que
no amenace Perdón la integridad de
soberanía territorial de China
en los balcanes seguimos haciendo
esfuerzos
para que haya paz y prosperidad y para
que se resuelvan todas las disputas de
una vez por todas a través del diálogos
a principios de septiembre
iniciamos una visita oficial a vos
tienes herzegovina Serbia y Croacia
después de concluir elecciones
felizmente en Bosnia
pienso que esto contribuirá mucho el
proceso de diálogo entre Belgrado y
pristina y lo cual contribuir a su vez a
la estabilidad de la región
Turquía en el Mar Egeo y en
el Mediterráneo Oriental quiere que se
resuelvan todos los problemas en el
marco de buenas relaciones de vecindad y
de conformidad con el derecho
internacional
Yo pienso que
los países que son potencias en
la región
tienen acciones lamentables
la estabilidad en el Mediterráneo
Oriental depende del respeto de los
derechos de todas las partes Esperamos
que Grecia abandone sus políticas de
tensión y de provocación y que atienda
nuestro llamado de cooperación y de
solidaridad pensamos que la conferencia
del Mediterráneo Oriental que hemos
propuesto servirá para este fin nuestro
interlocutores nunca han dado
un paso para
responder a nuestro llamado
y está claro quién está a favor de la
paz y quien está a favor de la atención
siempre tendremos nuestros derechos en
el Mar Egeo y en el Mediterráneo
Oriental nunca seremos
ante la estrategia de tensión de otros
países Incluso en la cuestión de chipre
queremos alcanzar una solución de una
vez por todas de una forma justa
y sostenible siempre hemos estado
expuestos a trabajar
con la República turca del norte de
chipre en esta Isla hay dos estados y
hay dos pueblos Y esto es el resultado
por todos
para alcanzar una salud una solución al
problema de la isla de chipre hay que
reconocer que los turcos chipriotas
tienen derechos iguales y soberanos
y que es que soltar su condición
internacional
queremos pedir a la comunidad
internacional que ponga fin
a las sanciones contra los turcos
chipriotas y que abandone todo tipo de
bloqueo
de una vez por todas
Grecia es un miembro de la Unión Europea
y ellos están expulsando a estos
refugiados Al Mar Egeo de una manera
inhumana
y también imponen ciertas políticas a
las minorías griegas de origen musulmán
haciendo caso mis otras sus
responsabilidades legales Esperamos que
Grecia ponga fin a estas prácticas
y pedimos a la Unión Europea
de hacer la vista gorda a estas
violaciones seis seguidos agregados cada
reto que experimentamos a nivel mundial
demuestra que hay una cooperación
importante entre Turquía y la Unión
Europea hemos celebrado el certajísimo
aniversario de nuestro ingreso a la otan
tenemos capacidad militar y contribuimos
a la seguridad de Europa y del planeta
estamos tratando de
alcanzar la seguridad y la estabilidad
del continente europeo
somos Asia en el occidente de Europa
y queremos aplicar objetos programas
tales como hacia de nuevo